None of you were there to see what happened.
None of you knows the truth.
You held a knife to his throat.
You said, I did warn you not to trust me.
Hey everybody big news the actors and
Game of Thrones revealed a huge deleted
scene that had something critical to do
with the big Sansa Littlefinger Branagh
so it's basically a deleted bran scene
so this is going to be a breakdown of that
and there is a new round of the game of
Thrones giveaway all you have to do to
enter that just be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video so
everybody's been doing a lot of
interviews with the actors and they've
been talking about scenes that didn't
make it into the final cut and because
there are a lot of big things that get
wrapped up in the finale there were a
lot of questions especially with this
Littlefinger plot so one of the biggest
things all season long is is when did
Arya and Sansa pick up on what
Littlefinger was doing and try to turn
the tables on him so it turns out that
there was a deleted scene in the finale
Isaac Hempstead Wright explains where
they actually do that that leads up to
this big surprise for Littlefinger that
it's not Arya that's on trial it's him
so I'll just read the quote from the
actor who plays bran about what that
scene was all about so he says we
actually did a scene that clearly got
cut a short scene with Sansa where she
knocks on brans door and says I need
your help or something along those lines
so basically as far as I know the story
was that it suddenly occurred to Sansa
that she had a huge CCTV Department at
her discretion and it might be a good
idea to check with him first before she
guts her own sister.
So tell me.
What's the worst thing she could want?
She could want me dead.
Because she thinks I wronged my family.
So she goes to Bran
and bran tells her everything
she needs to know and she's like oh!
When we were watching the finale that
was sort of my takeaway I just assumed
that somewhere between this scene with
sahn's and Littlefinger where he tries
to hypnotize her into coming to the
conclusion that Arya wants to be the
lady of Winterfell
in this scene here where they're all
confronting him as a pact where she went
to bran and he explained everything
about the dagger and all the things that
Littlefinger had done putting the pieces
together for her so Sansa is then like
oh crap I can't kill Arya Arya is my
friend Littlefinger is the one that we
need to kill but the reason why they
probably cut that out is one for time
and two so that it maintained the
surprise of the Littlefinger twist so
the unfortunate part of that is that it
makes everybody look really dumb and it
doesn't totally make sense at all and it
makes the director look like a bad
director because he didn't make it more
clear when the light bulb went on in the
actors heads like oh my god we figured
this out Littlefinger's been playing us
this whole time turns out that that
happened they just cut out the scene for
context that let you know that that
happened but a good comparison to make
would be like the dragon ex machina
where Daenerys comes to save everybody
when they're up in the north imagine
that they cut that entire Gendry scene
out with him running back and she just
showed up and they wanted you to assume
Oh somebody probably went and sent a
raven so that's kind of what they did
with the Littlefinger plot at Winterfell
but as far as deleted scenes go the only
other one that we know is confirmed is
that there was a ghost scene that the
writers wrote they just got cut for time
they actually filmed John saying goodbye
to ghost when he went to Dragonstone
earlier in the season just as a way to
let you know what was going on with
ghost but they cut it out so for all of
you asking where is ghost this whole
time he's still at Winterfell and you
know who knows if we're going to see him
again there's all these people talking
about the night king forming this wolf's
head with all the dead as that are
marching south of the wall I think
that's a hat tip to what's coming next
like we're coming for Winterfell if you
believe that that really looks like a
wolf's head which I'm not a hundred
percent on but I have seen a lot of
people speculating based on that
oh they're making a wolf set here that
must mean that bran is the night king no
I will say flat-out that does not
guarantee that bran is the night king
I'm still not a big fan of that theory
based on the evidence that people have
provided I'm going to need some stronger
evidence most of the evidence the people
of use in support of that have been
Photoshop jobs so it's been like fake
evidence that they've used to confirm
stuff it really the strongest evidence
against it is the fact that the actor
who plays the night king like when he's
underneath the makeup with the ice face
it's the same actor with this reddish
hair when he's tied to the tree back
during season six so these are the same
two people here it just is his makeup
makes his face look a little bit
different when he's wearing it but we
can talk about more night king stuff in
another video the really good Bran
scene I felt like probably one of the
best bran scenes all season long was
when Samwell came back because it let
Bran be funny again he's been this
piece of wood the entire season like
human turnip is not a good look for a
bran so you have to imagine that bran
is sort of like the Internet the
entirety of the Internet you can look up
anything that you want but Samwell is
the Google search bar that just types
stuff in so I feel like they'll continue
with that it just works so well in this
moment that why would you stop doing
that so the actor that plays bran was
asked about how he's going to tell Jon
Snow about his heritage and how they're
going to drop that big incest bomb so none
of the actors have seen their scripts
for Season eight yet they won't get
those for a couple more weeks so when
they're answering these questions it's
just them speculating on their own
characters so he said because his
personal skills are so terrible that
Samwell would probably be the one to
convey that information to Jon Snow so
the person to literally walk up to him
and say this is who you are this is who
your parents are this is what it all
means you're the heir to the Iron Throne
that will probably wind up being Samwell
because it's actually a pretty good idea
but it will be in the presence of bran
and everyone else so even though it's a
big critical thing it doesn't mean that
bran has to go sit by the fire or the
weirwood the entire time he can be
around for this
it's just that Samwell has some of the
more interpersonal skills that bran is
now lacking so in the way that the Hound
and Brienne is now like this really
touching funny duo hopefully we'll get
to see another moment with them you all
get stuff like that with bran and
samwell's storylines so I'm really
hoping that they just keep them right
next to each other for all of season
eight but the interesting thing that
they haven't talked about is this bran
as the three-eyed Raven now has access
to all this information but he also has
all these other powers too that they
haven't manifested yet so he can ward
big animals just like the night king can
Although, it's slightly different because he's
not working undead animals that's still
a big question mark so even though
they're only using bran is an
encyclopedia to drop these big plot
bombs there's actually a lot of other
things that he's capable of doing with
his powers
it's just that they might be waiting for
the army of the Dead to make it much
closer to Winterfell so when they're all
converging in the armies of the north
are trying to fight the army of the dead
then maybe we'll get to see bran new
some of his crazy powers but you have to
remember that for all the animals that
bran can control even if the golden
company with their giant elephants
they're bringing get controlled by bran
then they could still be turned by the
night king the minute that they fall in
battle so there's going to be some big
question marks about how they actually
physically go about fighting the army of
the dead especially if they're not going to
dip everybody's armor in dragonglass
there's still a bit of a question mark
about how you have to land a killing
blue with dragonglass will dragonglass
bombs be effective against them could
you actually miss the air and slow them
down a little bit so just remember the
real mission here is to crowd control
all of these whites while you gank all
the white walkers in the night King so
you really only need to kill them you
just need to keep this sea of dead
whites at bay so as long as you can find
something to keep them busy while you
kill the really important people then
you'll be fine you don't have to walk
around one at a time killing all those
hundred thousand whites but hopefully
that answers questions about the little
finger bran Sansa storyline this season
I think you know people were just a
little upset because it seemed like it
wasn't making sense and now we know
that's mostly because they were just
cutting scenes out wholesale so before
do they drop this bomb I was actually
working on an Aegon video that'll
probably be my next video and then I'll
talk about Tyrion Jamie and do other
character videos but leave all your
requests in the comments below there's
going to be a whole bunch of Game of
Thrones in the off season and we have
any
got into the book stuff yet so we'll say
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Baenos please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details your avatar
actually reminds me west world is going to
drop probably in the spring next year I
haven't started doing a lot of Westworld
videos but once they start dropping
footage will start talking about all
kinds of West world stuff but while you
wait for everything you can click here
for my season 8 predictions and you can
click here to learn about why Daenerys
might be able to get pregnant again
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!